in exact repeating alarms infinitely
better than exact repeating alarms but
still far from ideal the problem with
any kind of repeating alarm is that it's
still pulling your server to check for
updates so the more frequently you pull
the fresher the data you can display but
the higher the cost in battery life you
can pull less frequently to conserve
battery but that just means your content
will be stale for longer you could let
the user decide the update frequency
themselves but then you lose the magic
if only there was a better way it's such
a thing even possible yes it is Google
Cloud messaging lets your server notify
your app directly when there's data
ready to be downloaded or it can even
include the new data in the message
payload itself using Google Cloud
messaging you can send messages from
your server to any installed instance of
your app via the Google cloud as a
result you can stop polling which will
immediately improve battery life and
also improve the freshness of your app
and instead rely on your server
notifying clients when there's data to
sync these messages can be simple
tickles that trigger a sync adapter by
notifying your app that there is new
data ready to download or you can
include the new data within the message
payload in the sunshine example we're
using someone else's server but even
then it may make sense to create your
own middle tier that pulls the source
and notifies your installed app
instances when it notices a change now
we're not going to set up a server in
this lesson but you can see the full
details for using Google Cloud messaging
from the developer guide link to in the
instructor notes